[Music]
hello everyone welcome to Fandango indie
movie Guide I'm Alicia Malone and the
Oscars are done and dusted for another
year how did you go with your
predictions mine were pretty much as I
expected the biggest surprise for me was
in the Best Documentary category
I didn't think Icarus was gonna win and
take that prize I thought it would go to
faces places but let me know in the
comments below I want to hear from you
which was your biggest surprise award of
the evening and was there one that you
really wish went a different way anyway
let's get into the show and what's
coming out in theaters this weekend I
actually want to start with a movie that
came out last week but one you should
put on your radar and see this week if
you haven't already
it's called Midnighters and it is a
thriller all about a couple who get
themselves into a lot of trouble he's
going go back to the house someplace
where we can figure things out
this is our dress
it was honest I hear what starts out as
a simple premise goes through a lot of
twists and turns it's a little bit
convoluted at times but the thing that I
enjoyed the most was the mood of the
film really keeps you on the edge of
your seat it's very tense and it's one
of those rare horror thrillers where you
don't find yourself screaming at the
screen going what are you doing all the
decisions made by the characters are
things that you probably do yourself and
that makes it a little bit relatable and
somewhat scary and how you could
envision this actually happening you can
see Midnighters in select theaters right
now another thriller that is new out
this week has had a long road to the
screen I remember it played at Sundance
not this year but the year before hand
but it's an interesting little movie
that kind of has a Heather's vibe it's
directed by Cory Finley it's based on
his play it stars two great young
actresses both on the rise Olivia Cooke
and Anya Taylor joy you despise him hi
Mimi you can't go in looking like that
I'm fine I'm not gonna have to stand
here all day like robot repeating myself
I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine
everything by just killing him how would
you so it's very dark and disturbing the
kind of movie that makes you feel
something for very unlikable characters
it's also notable for being the final
performance for Anton Yelchin and it
just shows once again that we lost this
talent way too soon you got a gun yes a
gun you don't know where I come from
Westchester left me feeling like I
wanted more or that I wanted some kind
of bigger resolution for the characters
but overall it is a darkly funny little
indie you can see it in select theaters
from this weekend I wear a hat we're
keeping this by the way
and over on Fandango now you could see I
Tanya this is the movie that gave
allison janney her Oscar win and also
Margot Robbie was nominated for her role
playing Tonya Harding the haters always
say Tonya tell the truth there's no such
thing as truth everyone has their own
truth
it's a biopic about the biggest Gators
life it delves into media sensationalism
tabloid news class there's so much going
on here if you haven't seen a Tanya yet
or if you want to watch it again
you can see it on Fandango now right now
stop that and because tomorrow is
International Women's Day I thought I
would tell you about a playlist I put
together on Fandango now I'll put the
link below if you're watching this on
YouTube it's called the dynamic leading
lady's playlist and what I did was look
at a varied amount of films that had
great female lead characters doesn't
necessarily have to be a super hero
although Wonder Woman is in this
playlist
it can also be someone that is complex
that is dark that is maybe not the most
likable character like Charlize Theron
in monster each of the films I
hand-picked myself as having a female
character I found very interesting for
one reason or another so you can check
that out on Fandango now and support
some great female characters that we've
had throughout the years
I'm Alicia Malone you can find me at
Alicia Malone on Twitter and next week I
will be at South by Southwest so we tell
you about all the films that I recommend
you checking out from the festival see
you then bye